forming relationships can be very
challenging at work in our personal
lives in our romantic lives today let's
learn some skills to help us
I'm Matt Abrahams and I teach strategic
communication at Stanford Graduate
School of Business welcome to think fast
talk smart the podcast
I am super excited today to speak with
Rachel Greenwald Rachel is an executive
fellow at Harvard Business School and
interestingly a professional Matchmaker
and dating coach she's an expert on
communication and relationship building
in work love and life at Stanford
University she's co-taught a seminar
with past guest Tina selig at the D
school called designing for love she
also gets lectures with two of our other
previous guests Alison woodbrooks and
Naomi bagdonas welcome Rachel thanks for
being here
hi Matt I am so excited for our
conversation today I am too let's go
ahead and Jump Right In you help people
build relationships in two very
different Arenas you coach Executives in
the business world and you coach singles
in the dating world what have you
learned about one of the most
challenging aspects of relationship
building small talk that applies to both
worlds and how do you make small talk
feel more comfortable when meeting
someone at work or on a date
one big thing that I've learned about
creating successful Small Talk both at
work and on dates is simply this don't
be a data collector
so what I mean by that is like asking
where are you from what do you do how
many siblings do you have that is all so
boring to ask and boring to answer well
in all my research I just really
discovered again and again that boredom
is the enemy of small talk so many
people default to those predictable data
exchange topics so no wonder everybody
hates small talk or dreads it so your
goal instead should just try to be
intriguing so that someone wants to lean
in and get to know you I always say that
in the space between the expected and
the unexpected lies Intrigue if you want
to be intriguing you have to ask better
questions and you have to give better
answers when someone asks you a boring
question so I'll try to think of an
example here like if you're on a first
date and someone asks you a boring data
collection question like what do you do
always what everybody asks the first
thing so instead of just stating the
fact like I'm an engineer you could turn
it into an intriguing guessing game that
could sound something like what do I do
well let me give you two Clues and see
if you can guess I had to get a master's
degree for it and it usually involves
avocados
so that's a very unexpected answer right
it's intriguing and what I like best
about it is that it immediately signals
to the other person this is not going to
be your standard boring Small Talk
exchange it's going to be much more
enjoyable and and memorable it's just a
better conversation for both people I
want to know what kind of engineer uses
avocados you've definitely got me
Intrigue but this notion of engaging and
building Intrigue applies not just in
the dating world but I think in all of
our interactions when we talk at work
about a project we're on rather than
just giving the facts as you suggest we
could make it intriguing we could share
the potential value it brings I really
really like that idea and it helps us as
communicators reframe the whole purpose
because as you said so many of us dread
small talk and if if it becomes an
opportunity to engage and Intrigue
someone that all of a sudden makes it
much more interesting yeah absolutely
just don't try to collect data about the
other person just try to think that how
would I like to spend these next few
minutes myself I'm sure the other person
feels the same way let's try to make
this fun and intriguing absolutely
absolutely when it comes to Small Talk
Rachel in particular I find it and I
know many people find the initiation of
the small talk and how you get out of
the small talk how you end it to be
really challenging can you share ways
you coach people to start and end a
small talk
sure absolutely the the start and the
the ending are the toughest part so if
you're someone that struggles with
initiating small talk it's probably
because you're worried about finding
that intriguing question like we were
just talking about so if that's your
obstacle then I'd say just forget about
asking a question entirely take that
pressure away and instead think about
simply making an observation about
something in your environment so an
observation is essentially a bid for
connection and it can create a feeling
of instant familiarity like sort of a
conspiratorial Vibe just between two
people so what's an example like you
could say to someone standing next to
you in a networking event you know hey
that brownie over there on the buffet
should have a big sign that comes with
it that says this requires 75 minutes on
the Peloton you know something just any
observation Nation it doesn't have to be
funny but just something about your
Mutual environment can create a space
where the two of you can smile about
something right in front of you before
launching into the business of getting
to know each other so that's the
beginning of the small talk exchange
that I would suggest to make it easier
and that ending is super important also
I use actually in in coaching both my
daders and my Executives at work I use
this technique that I call the white
flag and the white flag is something
that people who know race car driving
will probably recognize the White Flag
in a race car situation is where
somebody stands at the Finish Line as
the cars are going around and around and
the person with a white flag right
before the last lap of the race will
throw down the white flag and that says
the race is almost over but there's one
more lab so for example like if you're
at a function a party whatever you could
say to somebody towards the end as
you're trying to wrap up your
conversation you could say before I go
get a drink I have one last question
because it was so great hearing about
your trip to Alaska I wonder if you have
a favorite hike to recommend in
Anchorage just in case I get out there
one day so then you listen to what they
recommend their favorite hike and then
as you're walking away you say something
like I really enjoy talking to you and
by the way I love your shoes so this is
something that's important to remember
that ending small talk is something in
social psychology that is called the
recency effect where people will rate
and experience more positively if the
last part of the experience is Pleasant
so ending your conversation with this
tactic like I have one last question and
then giving a compliment a sincere
compliment of course as you're walking
away just make someone feel like you
were genuinely listening to them and oh
by the way you admired something about
them when you first said White Flag I
thought you meant surrendering like I'm
giving up but but I do know auto racing
and I do know the White Flag analogy I
really like that idea I can totally see
how I could use that in conversation to
say I need to go over there I need to go
do this but before I do I'd like to
learn one more thing I think that's a
wonderful technique and really reminding
everybody of the recency effect that is
how we feel at the end of an interaction
really matters so doing something at the
end that's positive I think is great
rather than that awkwardness that many
of us feel where we just say I need
something more to drink and step away
from the person I really appreciate that
advice and I have an upcoming social
event for workben I'm going to use that
technique right away in terms of
starting I like that idea of finding
some kind of common ground or common
connection I can imagine in a work
function talking about a keynote speaker
or a certain goal that was just
discussed as a way of getting people to
initiate that conversation and together
be working towards getting the
conversation moving so very very helpful
I took copious notes on what you just
said and hope to put them into practice
in the very near future I know you and I
talked about this once when we first met
each other Rachel when I was in grad
school I published research on
flirtation and relationship initiation
this is a topic that really fascinated
me then and still fascinates me now and
it was also really helpful because I met
my wife while I was studying flirtation
in grad school now as a Matchmaker you
help many people initiate and start
relationships what advice do you give
daters about effective communication and
is there different advice you give
people who are seeking Romance Partners
versus those who are looking for
platonic and professional relationships
Matt is exactly the same advice in
romantic or professional context it's
not different at all and the advice is
simply to focus on how you make someone
feel more than you focus on the words
that you're saying so this reminiscent
of that Maya Angelou quote where
everyone knows this quote I'm sure but
people will forget what you said forget
what you did but never forget how you
made them feel
so instead of for example trying to
impress someone with your own stories or
your credentials you want to lean into
their stories their credentials and make
them feel smart or feel funny or even
just feel accepted instead of judged
which is how most people walk around
feeling every day is that everyone's
judging them so you can have comments
like somebody tells you something and
say something I don't know like wow I
never would have thought of doing that
how did you come up with that idea so
comments have to be genuine though like
that's really important you can't fake
interest in someone people can smell a
fake a mile away so try to have in your
head this Mantra that in every Gathering
every person in this room has something
to teach me and then your interest and
leaning into their stories will feel
more genuine you mentioned the word
flirtation in your question and whether
you use the word flirtation in a dating
context or whether you label it
something different in a work context
like relationship initiation it's
basically the same thing you're
demonstrating that you're interested in
someone and that you like them and it's
the universal truth that most people
will like you if you like them first I
really like that advice and as I was
listening to I was reminded of my my
late mother-in-law was an expert at
small talk and getting to know people
when she would come to visit she would
have to fly and the first half hour of
our conversations when she would arrive
would be about all the new friends she
made on the flight over and she and used
what I heard one of the techniques you
were talking about was genuine curiosity
she was very interested in people and
really liked getting to know people and
you could feel that in her super power
was being able to ask the question tell
me more I'd like to learn more what more
can you tell me about that and she would
I use that all the time to really get
conversations going and to signal that
she was really interested so I really
appreciate what you said and and I wish
we would have known each other back when
I was in grad school studying this you
would have helped me really hone in on
the things I was interested in studying
you work closely at times with some of
our most popular previous guests Allison
wood Brooks and Naomi bagdonis my
interviews with them looked into humor
and I'm curious to get your take on
using humor in conversations in our
personal lives and our professional
lives
word humor is always stressful and I
think I think it is to a lot of people
too because it feels daunting like
there's this pressure to be funny so I
and I don't think of myself as a funny
person so I try to rephrase that word
humor and I coach people on specifically
using light banter in conversation which
to me just sounds much easier less
pressure filled and it really
accomplishes the same goal which is to
lighten the mood
so for example we talked earlier about
finding observations in your environment
that are unexpected or playful and I
think that's a great starting point for
light banter observations could be
something like standing in a crowded
room and you turn to the person next to
you and you say something like I'm I'm
loving that woman's sweater over there
it's so Madonna Circa in 1985 or just
something it doesn't have to be funny
it's just sort of a light comment
but as you bring up humor I also want to
caution people that there's a dark side
to using humor in conversations most
people don't think about humor in any
negative way but it really can be if
it's used incorrectly so I conducted a
10-year dating research project where I
compiled a list of 13 bad conversation
habits and one of the bad habits I found
I called the comedian and the comedian
is someone in conversation who gets a
lot of laughs because they have jokes or
they are self-deprecating and at first
that's fun but
soon your conversation partner might
crave a deeper connection than just all
the laughs and someone who's the
comedian can use their humor like a
shield and your conversation partner
can't penetrate that Shield which will
feel frustrating to them you sort of
feel like as the conversation partner
you're an audience kept to the distance
from the performer and the comedian
always reminds me of crashing after a
sugar high you can feed too much
chocolate you might just suddenly
afterwards feel tired or unsatisfied and
so you have to remember that the goal of
communication is to create connection
and make a favorable impression so
obviously you don't want someone to feel
like talking to you is exhausting
because you're using humor too much in
your communication style I find the
first point you made to be really true
when we try to be funny it just invokes
so much stress address so I like your
reframing of hey this is just light
banter and that takes pressure off and
by taking pressure off I think it frees
us up to actually be funnier and more
connecting I am really curious to know
you said you found 13 bad conversation
habits can you just share with us two or
three more beyond the comedian yeah
absolutely one of the most common bad
habits people have was something I call
the mirror and the mirror is the dynamic
where whatever you say the other person
has a similar story to mirror back to
you like oh wow same thing happened to
me you're just waiting their turn
politely until you stop speaking so they
can reflect on their own relatables
experience and that's understandable
because I think we're taught when you're
younger or maybe even in some kind of
sales training programs they teach you
that you're supposed to find a point of
connection where you can relate to
somebody but actually I find it to be
the opposite I find that the mirror
habit can deflate conversational energy
or make it feel choppy so the exchange
can feel superficial and you don't feel
heard there's all sorts of other ones
like the interrupter somebody who's just
interrupting you before you can finish
your sentence and they try to finish
your sentence for you they're sure they
already know what they're going to say
so they have that dirty four-letter word
dynamic going on the k-n-o-w and the
other person just feels annoyed they
don't feel heard so all these
conversation bad habits are really about
the feeling you create in your
conversation partner so whether you're
trying to be the one upper or you're the
humble bragger or any of these 13 types
that I found
you are doing yourself a disservice
because you're almost trying to impress
the other person like I can understand
why they're behaving the way they are
but the end result is that your
conversation partner doesn't feel good
talking to you thank you for sharing
those and as you are going through each
of those bad communication behaviors I
saw in my mind's eye people who do those
skills and how they make me feel and the
The Meta message of what I heard you
share Rachel is that we constantly have
to be thinking about how we're making
our conversation Partners our co-workers
the people we're interested in dating
feel and not so much focus on our
particular goal in that moment which is
to share my story as soon as you share
yours and that is a wonderful reminder
of what makes for effective
communication be focused on the needs of
the person you're talking to before we
end I'd like to ask you the same three
questions questions I ask everyone are
you up for that Rachel yeah I'd love it
excellent I'm excited to hear your
answers if you were to capture the best
communication advice you've ever
received as a five to seven word
presentation slide title what would it
be
I would call this slide title
everyone knows it but you hmm what I
mean by that is that you have a
communication blind spot but you don't
know what it is everyone else knows and
you don't so maybe you even have more
than one blind spot but people are
terrible judges of their own
communication skills they either
overestimate or underestimate them they
have no idea how someone feels when
talking to you so you're the last to
know unless you ask for feedback so this
advice is all about trying to get
feedback and it's true in dating and
friendship and business anything
I didn't know where you're going to take
your slide title but I love the point
that we have to seek out feedback we are
not the best observers of our own
communication so for question number two
who is a communicator that you admire
and why for that question I am going to
pick someone kind of out of the standard
communication Arena
and point to someone named Priya Parker
who some of you may know others may not
she's the author of a book that is one
of my all-time favorites called The Art
of gathering and her work focuses on
reimagining how we spend our time
together to create more meaning so she's
not specifically in the field of
communication but she talks a lot about
setting the tone for a gathering before
it even begins and this is a point on
the Continuum of communication that I
think doesn't get enough attention and I
call that point the pre-communicating
point which is the idea that
communication actually begins in subtle
ways even before you're in the same
space with someone and space could be in
person or like you mentioned earlier it
could be a digital space like Zoom
and even email or text so space is
broadly defined but Priya Parker
Advocates that it's important to set the
tone before you interact with someone so
is your upcoming conversation or your
meeting going to be fun or do you want
it to be serious or is the emphasis on
being productive whatever it is
so if you think about all the
communication that happens before a
business meeting like calendar invites
or even the first few minutes in the
zoom window as people are logging on
before the meeting begins what if you
created a clever title for the calendar
invite or what if you played a theme
song on Zoom for the first 60 seconds
that reflects whatever your intended
mood is for this meeting I really like
her because I think in the big picture
you can have the best communication
skills on the planet but if people
aren't primed to come in being receptive
to you it's just really a missed
opportunity I really like priya's work
I've read the book I've heard her speak
and this notion of setting the table if
you will priming people is really
important we had a wonderful discussion
with Robert cialdini about what he calls
persuasion how you actually get people
in the right space for you then to make
the influence requests that you have we
don't spend enough time thinking about
the context for the community education
that we're about to have in highlighting
Priya Parker's work reminds us that we
need to do that we are going back to so
cology again and if you think about
Primacy effect is that people remember
the first piece of information they
encounter and that is better than
information presented later on so
pre-communication is difficult to master
but Priya Parker knows how to set up
future conversations for success by
communicating in advance what she hopes
to accomplish absolutely question number
three what are the first three
ingredients that go into a successful
communication recipe oh I love that
question the first thing that comes to
mind is the expression I'm going to
steal from Real Estate so in real estate
you probably know the advice for buying
a valuable property as location location
so I am going to say the same as similar
in communication which is listen listen
listen that is so important that it
Bears repeating three times so people
whether it's business or dating they put
so much emphasis in communication on
what to say but really successful
communication is about active listening
and I use the word active intentionally
because I don't mean just listening like
stop talking or be quiet or let the
other person speak but actively
listening means things like don't plan
your next response don't be listening to
what somebody's saying and secretly
thinking about how you're going to
respond and active listening means ask
follow-up questions instead of Shifting
the topic back to yourself and probably
most of all active listening is about
encouraging someone to elaborate I love
those ingredients you know Rachel I
really thank you for taking time to be
with us and give us very specific advice
on how we can connect better with
co-workers potential romantic partners
and platonic friends I appreciate your
time I appreciate your input thank you
oh you're so welcome
thanks for joining us for another
episode of think fast talk smart the
podcast from Stanford Graduate School of
Business this episode was produced by
Jenny Luna Ryan Campos and me Matt
Abrahams our music was provided by Floyd
Wonder for more information and episodes
find us on YouTube or wherever you get
your podcasts thank you and please make
sure to subscribe and follow us on
LinkedIn